eu queria pedir atenção todo mundo pra
essa folha
tá vocês estão vendo que essa folha a
folha não tem nada desenhado nem à
frente nem atrás já aviso que não é um
truque de mágica
eu não vou tirar nenhum coelho e
daminhas vagas nem nada mas eu vou pedir
pra você ver essa folha e depois eu peço
que vocês voltem pra esse pensamento da
folha que eu vou explicar a eu trabalho
na cufa como coordenando desde 2009 mas
eu participei lá em 2007 da primeira
formação de audiovisual ministrada pelo
manoel soares que é o nosso coordenador
e por o acaso do destino meu irmão mais
velho também é eu gosto de dizer que eu
sobrevivi ele né am em 2009 as
comunidades aqui do rio grande do sul as
favelas aqui no rio grande do sul
elas se depararam com um monstro que ele
era muito forte que é a questão do crack
as pessoas estavam morrendo às com a
comunidade foi muito atingida as
famílias e os jovens principalmente e há
muitos anos o craque já existe né
desde 93 nacionais já falava de crack
nas músicas dele mas esse ano foi
específico no que foi muito violento
foi então que junto com manoel e com
toda a equipe da curva a gente decidiu
fazer alguma coisa na questão não é
porque nós eram os títulos nós somos uma
instituição social ea gente tinha que
dar um ponto inicial para tentar lidar
com essa situação a gente entender o que
nós somos uma instituição social que
trabalha com educação então tratar essa
pessoa dependente não era o nosso
trabalho é uma questão de saúde pública
e reprimir a questão da violência também
não era o nosso trabalho porque são a
questão de políticas públicas de
segurança
então a culpa decidiu trabalhar com uma
coisa que eu acho que é fundamental é
muito importante uma coisa chamada
prevenção prevenção é você chegar na
vida desse jovem dessa mulher desse
homem
idoso e mudar a história dele antes que
ele acesse e porque eu falo homem mulher
e idoso criança porque quando eu tô
falando do monstro que a droga seja ela
personificado em qualquer coisa a gente
está falando de uma instituição que não
tem preconceitos
a droga é uma instituição que abraça a
qualquer pessoa homem mulher criança
adulto velho hetero ou homossexual não
importa
e esse poder de abraçada droga é um
poder que acaba sendo algo que como nós
que trabalhamos com essa coisa de você e
para o convencimento para a mediação de
conflito é muito difícil
foi então que a gente decidiu criar um
livro chamado escudeiro da luz em os
hubs da pedra que é uma publicação que
mostra de um menino que tem um problema
de drogas a nossa família e ele cria um
super herói que ajuda a ele resolver
esse problema ia lidar com essa situação
foi dessa forma que a gente tentou lhe
dar nas comunidades de crianças e
adolescentes de uma forma lúdica mas
mostrando que se você quer mudar sua
vida você pode ir pra você mudar eo e
vencer a gente explica como uma criança
pode se tornar um escudeiro da luz
mas para chegar nesse livro 2009 esse
livro ele não trabalha só questão de
invisibilidade não tira o jovem da base
da invisibilidade somente nova que
participa da oficina esse livro também
me tirou da invisibilidade
eu era esse jovem morador de periferia
né filho de faxineira com muito orgulho
que criou nós os seis filhos e nos
ensinou que era social antes da gente
saber o que era social ajudando os
parentes das pessoas pagando passagem
nénão termo carinhoso para vagabundo no
ônibus pensando que alguém poderia fazer
pelos filhos dela então lá em 2009 manel
virou pra mim e falou olha a gente vai
fazer esse livro você vai desenhar esse
livro eu tinha 17 anos de idade e eu
peguei aquela coisa assim nossa vou ter
que lidar com esse com essa situação e
uma das coisas que eu me cobrava muito é
que por trabalhar com quadrinhos sempre
gostar de ilustração eu tinha que ser o
cara que iria revolucionar o mercado de
quadrinhos brasileiro e me botava
peso e eu tinha que mudar a história
tinha que fazer mas na verdade cara eu
não era obrigado a fazer nada disso foi
só depois disso de entender que eu não
precisava ser um gênio nem revolucionar
aquilo que eu entendi que era minha
missão ea minha missão era a partir
desses desenhos passar a minha história
e passar traduzir os problemas da
sociedade para outras pessoas para que
todo mundo pudesse lidar com isso mas
parece para esse projeto acontecer e eu
com 17 anos tenho que trabalhar
eu tive que fazer uma coisa que é muito
interessante e vou pedir ajuda da moça
ah eu não tinha muito material eu tinha
que correr eu passei três meses
confinado dentro de uma sala
tá e pra quem é desenhista sabe que você
tem que trabalhar com o desenho no aps e
arte finalizar
para finalizar melhor eu tinha que usar
uma mesa de luz mas eu não tinha não
tinha bendita mesa de luz aí que entendi
que a necessidade é a mãe da
criatividade
fui na caixa de ferramenta do irmão josé
nilto peguei e arranquei a tampa do
fogão da minha mãe está aqui a prova do
crime dois livros já passaram por cima
dessa tampa de fogão mãe me desculpa ah
eu fiz uma promessa que no dia que a
instituição a curva aqui no rio grande
do sul tivesse um lugar bacana eu iria
colocar uma sala em nome desse fogão que
sacrificou tá pra que esse projeto
acontecesse
então a partir disso a emi virando e
acontecendo eu fiz esse livro e não
tinha a menor idéia do potencial do
alcance que ele que ele iria ter
obrigado anos depois em 2015
manuel nosso coordenador me ligou e
falou cara a comunidade mudou e agentes
abordaram o tema que era a questão do
primeiro contato do jovem com o mundo do
crime
esse contato geralmente é invisível os
educadores os pais
todas estão na volta eles não percebem
esse primeiro contato é uma carteira na
bolsa da mãe que está de bobeira é um
tênis no varal é uma camiseta você tem
que comprar a camisa de alguém que não
pode ser como ele
e geralmente se você não está presente
como educador para orientar esse jovem
esse mundo do crime que é sedutor ele
acaba te abraçando e te levando então a
nossa ideia era criar a história de um
menino que foi baseada numa história
real de que roubava o objeto e ele tinha
que lidar com essa situação todo o
conflito interno dentro dele
só que quem trabalha com social não é
muito certo na cabeça quando você entra
na área social é um bichinho que timóteo
você fica meio maluco como manoel foi a
mesma coisa ele foi mordido e
contaminando o resto da família
como eu disse na minha mãe já havia
trazido isso e aí a gente entender o que
o primeiro livro nós trazíamos a solução
pronta para o jovem talvez não pronta
mas a gente trabalhava com isso
neste livro a gente decidiu fazer
diferente neste livro a gente decidiu
não colocar um final e o final é escrito
por cada jovem dentro da sala de aula na
escola pública em porto alegre
então a partir das oficinas que nós a
cufa chegamos na escola com o pas o
professor parceiro esses jovens se
coloca no lugar do personagem principal
que é o denis e aí ele decide o final
desse personagem porque que a gente fez
isso e é muito importante e aí vem a
questão do tema da minha palestra a que
é preciso vencer visibilidade
esse jovem que era invisível que é
invisível e eu também sou invisível
fui e graças à cuf esse projeto sair
dessa condição esse jovem ele foi
avaliado como parte do problema
a partir do momento que você coloca a
solução na mão dele e você dá pra ele
poder de decisão de mudar se o seu mundo
ea sua história ele sai da posição de
problema pra ir para a posição de
solução então ele se torna protagonista
da própria história e aí não é o daniel
nem manuel nem dona ivonete que vai
chegar lá na escola 19 tem que fazer o
que é certo e errado não ele decide e
por trabalhar dentro das comunidades
essa aqui é uma comunidade onde eu
cresci que o morro santa teresa e aí eu
decidi colocar isso na história é que é
bem um momento onde a gente saía e o que
acontece por morar dentro da periferia
durante toda a minha vida por enxergar
somente no santa tereza na cruzeiro que
nos últimos anos tem sido palco de um
monte de mazelas e morte
eu esperava que os finais dos livros
desses jovens fosse traduzir isso uma
dor ou rancor vingança e só o ano
passado eu trabalhei diretamente com
mais de 13 mil jovens
então quando esse livro foi para a
escola eu fiz questão de trabalhar turma
por turma durante o ano inteiro e uma
coisa que eu fiquei assim muito
impressionado os finais não tinham
nenhum pingo de dor de vingança eles não
queriam se vingar de ninguém e eles não
queriam dar o troco na sociedade muito
pelo contrário eles queriam mudar a
história a partir do momento que eles se
tornaram o denis e eles puderam fazer a
escolha eles decidiram que eles queriam
uma coisa melhor pra eles e não só num
ato de egoísmo também para a comunidade
então eles buscavam a solução para si e
para a comunidade uma coisa muito
importante
o perdão da mãe era algo que era
evidente em todos os lugares
todos os sinais que eu vi o principal
objetivo deles era pedir perdão para a
mãe se organizar com ela porque a mãe é
essa figura que foi pra mim essa mulher
guerreira que está ali que tem
trabalhado em 34 serviço e te dá
dignidade ela não serve só arroz e
feijão ela serve na sua mesa dignidade e
foi isso que eu aprendi que esses jogos
também aprenderam então vou pedir de
novo à folha que acontece se eu
perguntar pra um computador o que ele
enxerga quando ele olha essa folha esse
contador vai chegar talvez tabelas
rendimentos se eu perguntar para o
músico o que ele enxerga nessa folha que
ele vai dizer ah eu vejo uma partitura
como a gente viu né
vejam a partitura uma composição eu como
desenhista pode parecer meio maluco mas
quando olha essa folha eu vejo o futuro
como esse futuro por ter que construir
uma ilustração nessa folha eu já tenho
que está pensando em algo que já existe
na minha cabeça pelo menos
então assim eu 'tô' olhando todo medindo
avaliações quais as técnicas que eu vou
usar o que vai implementar e com a idéia
da administração
só que quando eu falo na questão social
eu falo na questão da invisibilidade
essa folha é um jovem que está sendo
morto que faz parte de uma chacina aqui
no brasil
este é um jovem que eu recebo eu
adoraria que esses jovens chegasse assim
bonito vizinho pronto para ser usado mas
esse jovem não chega assim esse jovem
chegará assim pra pessoa
daniel e moka seja cara porcaria escroto
é uma só folha se o moleque mas respeito
os adolescente aí cara a eu sei mas
gente
esse é o jovem que eu trabalho todos os
dias a vida deixa essas cicatrizes nesse
jogo e se eu como educador e como o cara
que com agente social educador social
não quiser trabalhar com isso
eu estou deixando esse jovem andar na
corda bamba e indo pro futuro que é
certo é preciso mudar
então o que eu posso deixar aqui pra
vocês
quando você se depararem com um jovem
com essas cicatrizes mostra em pra ele
que ele não precisa ter vergonha disso
essas marcas não fazem mais fraco o
fazem mais forte muito mais forte
essas marcas podem trazer traumas mas
elas trazem uma sensibilidade que
nenhuma faculdade vai ensinar para ele
que nenhuma religião que nenhum conceito
e se você mostrar pra ele que ele pode
ter orgulho do passado porque sem
passado ninguém existe e ele tiver força
de vontade de trabalhar o seu presente
com certeza o futuro dele vai ser
maravilhoso
vamos abraçar esses jovens e abraçar é
você poder potencializar porque essa é a
minha ferramenta no combate à
invisibilidade
você deve estar pensando pô mas eu não
tenho essa ferramenta é um trabalho com
desenho
essa ferramenta pode ser um violão uma
bola de basquete
uma fotografia um instrumento qualquer
coisa e se você não tem essa ferramenta
se ali a quem tem de força pra quem tem
porque o meu maior objetivo de vida é
acabar com aquele discurso de que se a
gente salvar pelo menos 11 o nosso
trabalho também feito
não eu não acredito nisso nós temos que
salvar o máximo de jovens possíveis
porque esses jovens eles não são o
futuro eles são o nosso presente eo
nosso presidente está morrendo
então assim se a linq pode fazer e
também construir um futuro melhor e um
presente melhor para esses jovens
muito obrigado